Like if we're out at a store
or something running an errand
he'll tell the workers you better
watch out for her because she steals
But do you understand how
that might make her feel?
Like a criminal
Exactly
I mean i used to steal
Okay
You used to steal what did you...I
was totally kidding around
no this is a breakthrough
I stole skittles from blockbuster
I stole a stick of gum once from the market
I stole a bracelet from Express
I stole another bracelet from Express
that someone told me to return
I stole a headband from urban outfitters once
I stole a hat
This this list doesn't end! This is a crime
spree that the Hillside Strangler would envy